lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
analizar lo que significa el valor
promedio de una función sobre un
intervalo cerrado
veamos qué quiere decir eso del valor
promedio de una función para esto
supongamos que este es mi eje y y este
de aquí este de aquí es mi eje x y por
aquí tenemos la gráfica de nuestra
función ye yé igual a fx y ahora
consideremos un intervalo cerrado un
intervalo que inicia en a y termina en b
incluyendo los valores de los extremos a
y b eso es lo que determina que el
intervalo sea cerrado entonces para x
entre a y b que es lo que significa el
valor promedio de esta función podríamos
pensar que representa la altura promedio
de esta función pero aún así qué
significa esta altura promedio está la
podríamos pensar como la altura de un
rectángulo que si la multiplicamos por
la base que es la longitud del intervalo
obtendríamos el área bajo la curva es
decir el área bajo la curva que tenemos
aquí
déjame hacerlo con otro color así es que
el área bajo la curva que tenemos aquí
que estoy rellenando en amarillo esto ya
sabemos que lo puedes calcular como la
integral definida desde
esta vez de fx de x de tal manera que
cuando nosotros calculamos el valor
promedio de la función sobre el
intervalo cerrado déjame escribirlo aquí
sobre el intervalo cerrado que va de a a
b incluyendo a llave y ese valor
promedio lo vamos a representar como una
altura la voy a poner aquí con otro
color esta que vamos a llamar la altura
promedio aquí lo tenemos lo que sería el
valor primero de la función de tal
manera que si yo multiplico esta altura
por la base de un rectángulo que la
distancia de ave voy a obtener el área
de un rectángulo que sería el área de
este rectángulo cuyo valor es
exactamente el mismo del área bajo la
curva lo cual hace sentido si te
recuerdas cómo calcular una manera de
calcular el área de un trapezoide para
lo cual multiplicas el promedio de las
bases por la altura veámoslo sí aquí
tenemos un trapezoide un trapezoide como
éste para el cual su área
la calculamos multiplicando la altura
el promedio de las bases así es que este
sería este de aquí sería el promedio de
las bases que en un trapecio regular
está justo a la mitad esta función no es
lineal así es que aquí no va a estar
exactamente a la mitad pero el concepto
es similar así es que como podemos usar
esta idea si a esta altura que tenemos
aquí la llamamos el promedio de la
función si este valor corresponde al
promedio de la función como podemos
obtener una fórmula que nos permita
calcular el promedio de la función sobre
el intervalo cerrado bien eso ya lo
mencionamos dijimos que este valor
promedio de la función vamos a ponerlo
aquí el valor promedio de la función
corresponde a la altura de un rectángulo
cuya base corresponde a la longitud del
intervalo cerrado la cual podemos
calcular como el mayor menos el menor b
menos a es lo que mide la base de ese
rectángulo así es que se multiplicó la
altura el promedio la función por b
menos a esto nos proporciona el área de
ese rectángulo que es equivalente al
bajo la curva es decir esto es igual a
la integral de a a b de fx de x una vez
que tenemos esto podemos despejar el
valor promedio de la función dividiendo
ambos lados entre b menos a obtenemos
que el promedio de la función es igual
1 sobre venenosa
que multiplica a la integral de a ave de
fx de x otra manera de ver esto es que
vas a dividir el área bajo la curva
sobre la longitud del intervalo para
obtener el valor promedio de la función
el cual podemos ver como la altura
promedio quiero insistir en que no
tienes que memorizar esto simplemente
entender lo que esta fórmula representa
si tomamos el área bajo la curva y la
dividimos entre la longitud del
intervalo obtenemos la altura promedio
la cual corresponde al valor promedio de
la función en el siguiente vídeo
aplicaremos esta fórmula la cual una vez
que se obtiene el valor de esta integral
se calcula de manera inmediata